dans le cadre de la 50e saison de
l'émission on vous présente aujourd'hui
un grand dossier sur la forêt au canada
est un écosystème immense qui est plus
fragile qu'on pourrait le croire
il est soumis à une foule de changements
qui vont aller en s'intensifiant et déjà
des chercheurs sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
arriver à décrypter la forêt du futur
[Musique]
la foire est couvrent près du tiers de
la surface du globe et elle nous rend
d'innombrables services
elles captent le co2 dans l'atmosphère
le converti en carbone et le séquestre
pendant un certain temps
elle produit de l'oxygène et capte les
poussières et les polluants présents
dans l'air elle le retient et filtres
une partie des eaux de pluie limite les
inondations et prévient l'érosion
c'est un habitat qui abrite une
remarquable diversité d'espèces
végétales et animales
il sert à la fois de refuge et de
garde-manger la récolte la
transformation et le commerce des
produits forestiers ainsi que les
activités récréatives en forêt ont une
immense valeur économique social et
culturel
on trouve au canada parmi les plus
grandes forêts au monde dont le tiers
des forêts boréales de la planète
mais une menace plane sur new forest
[Musique]
le changement climatique épidémies
d'insectes plus fréquentes et plus
dévastatrices
feux plus intenses tempêtes sécheresses
inondations risquent de fragiliser les
forêts et les industries et les
communautés qui en dépend les chercheurs
sont à pied d'oeuvre pour mieux
comprendre les effets du changement
climatique et pour développer des
modèles de gestion durable qui réduiront
la vulnérabilité de nos forêts
[Musique]
à valcartier près de québec se cache une
jeune forêt sous haute surveillance
seul un groupe de chercheurs du service
canadien des forêts que pénétrer dans
cette enceinte clôturée
on y trouve 24 parcelles d'arbus la
moitié est maintenu à température
ambiante
les douze autres parcelles sont chauffés
en continu à deux degrés de plus du
début mai jusqu'en octobre
ce projet expérimental mis en place il
ya cinq ans a été baptisé tifa il permet
de simuler l'effet des changements
climatiques anticipées d'ici 2050 on le
plante est ici des semis de sapin
baumier déclin puis 2-2 provenance des
provenances qui vient du nord des
provinces qui sont plus au sud puis on
veut garder commun que ces espèces lors
vont réagir à l'impact des changements
climatiques
les chercheurs étudient les effets du
réchauffement sur le débourrement des
arbres c'est à dire l'éclosion des
bourgeons et aussi la vulnérabilité de
ces arbres à la défoliation par la
tordeuse des bourgeons de l'épinette
l'insecte qui fait le plus de ravages
dans les peuplements de conifères en
amérique du nord
malgré son nom la tordeuse s'attaque
principalement au sapin baumier elle se
nourrit de jeunes pousses de résineux et
la période d'alimentation des lave et
bien synchronisés avec l'éclosion des
bourgeons du sapin baumier autrement dit
l'insecte et son hôte le sapin sont
synchrones l'épinette noire elle
débourse plus tard or les chercheurs
craignent que ça change
avec le réchauffement climatique pour le
vérifier il dépose au printemps des
landes de tordeuses élevé en laboratoire
sur les arbres des parcelles
expérimentales et il les recouvre deux
filets pour les protéger des
parasitoïdes puis pendant la saison de
croissance une équipe surveille
étroitement le débourrement des jeunes
sapins épinettes et mesure la croissance
des pousses déjà pour les sept qui sont
chauffés on voit une différence au
niveau de l'ouverture des bourses
le réchauffement de vence l'éclosion des
bourgeons de deux à trois jours et il y
a un meilleur synchronisme entre le
débourrement de l'épinette noire et
l'émergence de la tordeuse une sérieuse
menace pour cette espèce qui a contribué
à l'essor de l'industrie forestière
québécoise
on a beau dire que oui à mme labbé
nettoie et un autre qui est assez bon
que la sapin pour pour la tendance en
conséquence on peut avoir une
augmentation à dans la défoliation
désert possible
les chercheurs étudient aussi
l'hypothèse voulant que les arbres qui
viennent du sud réagissent mieux au
réchauffement que ceux qui viennent du
nord
le résultat de leurs travaux pourraient
éventuellement permettre aux forestiers
de planter des essences dont la
provenance est mieux adaptée au climat
son propos la bonne provenance mais qui
ont beaucoup mortalité mais on n'aura
pas le produit convenance en 53 30
ultime mans on espère ainsi revoir et de
manière durable et maintenir la
biodiversité la santé et la productivité
des forêts
[Musique]
la forêt montmorency située à quelque 70
km de la ville de québec est aussi un
formidable terrain de jeu pour les
chercheurs 38 on reste ici différentes
pratiques d'aménagement entre autres
pour mieux protéger la forêt contre les
épidémies de tordeuse des bourgeons de
l'épinette
on s'amuse avec une scie à chaîne à
ouvrir le peuple m'a sorti un certain
nombre de tiges assez pour que ce soit
rentable pour ouvrir nos portes
le peuplement ce qui nous permet de
jouer avec la résistance des armes qui
restent sur place ont vu ainsi favoriser
les jeunes forêts qui ont des armes
naturelles redoutable contre la tordeuse
elles produisent en abondance deux
séries de molécules chimiques toxiques
pour l'insecte la première série ce
qu'on appelle les volontaires pnc les
odeurs de certains sont rentrés nambot
vous avez cette odeur de sas à contrôler
l'appétit d'un sexe sont son rythme
d'alimentation lien en or de ségou de
mauvais whimarsh piano série composée
qu'on m'appelle est annoncée ce qu'on
trouve en vain c'est toxique et quand
les armes sont aux jeunes c'est de
composer des chansons beaucoup ces
composés toxiques sont moins abondants
dans les forêts plus vieille ce qui
favorise les épidémies de tordeuses mais
l'insecte a une capacité d'adaptation
phénoménale et la donne pourrait changer
avec le réchauffement
mais ce qui inquiète par dessus tout
éric bauce c'est la spongieuse la montée
de cet insecte vers le nord est bloqué
présentement parce que c'est eux
résistent mal au gel mais évidemment si
fait plus chaud bas et les populations
vont augmenter et il faut comprendre la
plongeuse un échec assez inquiétant
parce que la tordeuse mange à peu près 3
4 sortes d'arbres responchons manche
sans en 36 heures
la chercheuse evelyne tifo elle évalue
l'effet des coupes partiel sur la
résilience et la résistance des
peuplements au changement climatique
donc la coupe partie à la différence
c'est qu'au lieu d'enlever la plus
grande partie couverts du couvert
d'arbres
tu gardes une partie d un plan large sur
30 ou 40% du couvert elle veut voir si
une coupe partiel permet aux espèces de
mieux se reproduire et de pousser plus
vite qu'avec une coupe total le modèle
privilégié au québec en forêt boréale
pour se projeter plus loin dans l'avenir
la chercheuse utilisent des modèles de
simulation ses modèles laisse croire
qu'au cours des 30 prochaines années le
réchauffement devrait d'abord favoriser
la croissance des résineux après le
scénario change là nos espèces
résineuses vont commencer à avoir du
trouble vont avoir plus et mesurera à
pousser à se régénérer et ils vont
perdre vont perdre du chemin et c'est
d'autres espèces auxquelles on n'est pas
habitués ou peu habitué en forêt boréale
qui vont commencer à a dominé donc on
verra de plus en plus d'espèces pu
prendre le dessus tranquillement sur nos
espèces résineuses
[Musique]
les forêts jouent un rôle important dans
la lutte aux changements climatiques
en agissant comme des puits de carbone
elle capte le dioxyde de carbone de
l'atmosphère la photosynthèse sépare le
carbone et l'oxygène l'oxygène est
rejeté dans l'atmosphère mais le carbone
lui est stockée pour un temps dans les
arbres et le sol pour un temps parce que
lorsque les arbres meurent se décompose
où brûlent une bonne partie de ce qui a
été piégé et relâché dans l'atmosphère
sous forme de dioxyde de carbone la
forêt devient alors une source de
carbone
dans la forêt montmorency les chercheurs
veulent vérifier si les coupes partiel
favorise la séquestration du carbone
stéphane tremblay étudie les effets de
la coupe progressive et régulière ici et
là procédé à une série de coupes partiel
successives pour régénérer les essences
désiré et donner plus de structures et
de diversité au peuplement forestier
on parle de coop d'environ 30 40 % mais
qui sont faites à toutes les trente
quarante cinquante soixante dix ans ça
dépend des à 106 si on étend sa crinière
pour pense plus à quelque chose comme 20
25 ans puis dans ce modèle là souvent il
n'y a pas de coût final il ya toujours
des hommes matures qui sont présents
dans le couvert qui forme le couvert
avec des arbres de plus petite dimension
en préservant une partie du couvert
forestier il y aurait moins de
décomposition au sol et la forêt
émettrait moins de carbone les arbres
matures pourrait aussi s'avérer moins
vulnérables aux sécheresses au chablis
et aux épidémies d'insectes et on
pourrait les utiliser dans la
fabrication de produits à valeur ajoutée
qui stockent le carbone d'autres travaux
de recherches se font tous dessus de la
canopée à 15 mètres dans les airs
cette tour permet justement de mesurer
les flux de carbone donc de voir jusqu'à
quel point la forêt dégage du carbone
vers l'atmosphère
le professeur françois anctil s'en sert
aussi pour étudier l'évolution du régime
hydrologique sous le changement
climatique
le secteur de la fois remords insiste un
château d'eau c'est plus la menthe et
demi de précipitations chaque année je
suis toute cette eau là et une partie
qui retourne dans l'atmosphère par
évaporation tous et se terminera qui
nous intéresse le plus parce qu'on
s'attend que ce changement climatique
l'évaporation voit augmenter
[Musique]
la vapeur d'eau invisible est difficile
à mesurer
pour y arriver on utilise des
instruments spécialisés dont
l'anémomètre ultrasonique et
l'hygromètre et on mesure la vitesse du
vent la teneur en humidité dans l'air au
rayonnement solaire et le rayonnement
émis par la terre puis en fait on en
vient à mesurer le transport vers le
haut
de la vapeur d'eau qui libérait soit par
les impôts transpiration ou soit la
surface des feuilles par l'évaporation
ou le sol avec le réchauffement les
modèles climatiques prédisent une
augmentation de l'évaporation dans le
bassin versant de la forêt montmorency
présentement c'est de l'ordre de 5 à 600
mm par année mais ça va augmenter
puis massez de l'eau qui sera pu sortir
plus du bassin versant
donc les rivières vont voir leur débit
diminuer parce qu'il y aura plus d'eau
qui va être tourné directement à
l'atmosphère et la disponibilité en eau
affectent la production forestière en
période de sécheresse la plupart des
arbres transpire - règle générale la
quasi totalité de l'eau qu'il puise est
évaporée par les stomates de petites
ouvertures sur les feuilles lorsqu'ils
sont en stress hydrique les arbres
bloquent ces stomates l'eau ne peut plus
progresser jusqu'à la cime et le passage
du gaz carbonique est essentielle à la
photosynthèse est bloqué lui aussi
à long terme une augmentation de
l'évaporation pourrait transformer le
paysage de la forêt montmorency le sapin
baumier évolue bien dans un milieu
humide des stress hydriques prolongée
pourrait menacer sa survie
les recherches menées sur le territoire
de la forêt montmorency devrait donc
permettre de mieux prédire l'évolution
de la forêt boréale et d'adapter les
pratiques sylvicoles pour qu'elle puisse
répondre à nos besoins futurs
[Musique]
à